To access the classroom videos,
you'll click Classroom.
Within a given course,
you'll see a few things.
Up here, you'll see a drop down
box with a list of lessons.
>> Typically, your class will give you
a separate calendar telling you when you
should watch each lesson.
>> Click on any lesson to
jump straight to that lesson.
These bars across the top will indicate
your progress through the lesson.
The orange indicates
what video you're on now,
the blue are those that
you have already watched.
The grey are those you have yet to watch
and the dots here indicate exercises.
So we'll talk about those next.
>> Real quick though,
note also that below videos you
may find some instructor notes
as well as additional links to
the downloadables for that video.
There are also a couple options you
can turn on when viewing the videos
on Udacity.
You can click the CC button to turn
the closed captions on and off, and
if you click the gear,
you can adjust the speed of the video.